best-selling author viet tan win is out
this week with the sequel to his
pulitzer prize-winning novel the
sympathizer
the committed continues the story of the
refugee narrator
from wynn's first book together the
novels have earned him the description
as
a new conscience of american literature
jan crawford spoke with the author about
his harrowing escape as a child
from war-torn vietnam and how it helped
form his creative voice
we invited tanwen to share a meal with
us
him los angeles and me in washington d.c
hoping food would open a window into his
upbringing when you're an immigrant or
refugee to a country that's not your own
food becomes really important because
it's obviously symbolic of your culture
and symbolic of love when it came to
food we followed nguyen's lead
i guess i should order now to get the
ball rolling
and caught a glimpse of the dual
identities that are ever present in his
writing
should we go ahead and eat yeah
absolutely i tried to order stuff that
wouldn't be too messy you're
um you're vietnamese but america made
you
i grew up feeling like a spy because in
my
parents very vietnamese household i was
an american spying on these strange
vietnamese customs and then i would step
outside into the american world
and feel like i was a vietnamese spying
on these strange americans
that feeling led nguyen to his
breakthrough character
an unnamed vietnamese communist spy his
debut novel sold
more than a million copies and earned
countless accolades for its look
at the american war in vietnam from the
vietnamese perspective
you talk about the idea of kind of
nuanced patriotism
which means you can be thankful but also
critical
this country has always been marked by
conflicts and controversies and debates
about who we are and
what our principles are and if americans
white americans can do this without
being told to go home
or leave then why can't the newcomers
his new book the committed
sends his protagonist to paris where he
becomes immersed in a world of drugs and
organized crime
in the committed i say hey look at
france they have ideals and they fail
too
so i think i don't think there's any
shame in that in this sequel he's
determined to present a more complete
version of the refugee story
writing in the opening lines society
views refugees as
the unwanted the unneeded and the unseen
you refuse to call yourself an immigrant
you're a refugee
the unwanted as you put it in my work i
try to stress
these people they may be desperate and
frightened and scared and so on
but they're also really heroic i mean a
lot of the people who took to these seas
then and now know that their odds of
survival are really really bad
that to me is bravery and heroism and
that needs to be acknowledged
in our stories and in our capacity to
call ourselves with pride
refugees nguyen's own life story
reflects the promise
and pain of america like some 130 000
other refugees
nguyen's family fled vietnam when he was
just four years old
his earliest memories are of the refugee
camp in pennsylvania where they ended up
and they weren't always welcomed you'll
just probably take jobs away from
people that need jobs around here in
order to leave we had to have american
sponsors
but there wasn't an american sponsor
willing to take all four of us so one
sponsor took my parents one sponsor took
my ten-year-old brother one sponsor took
four-year-old me
and of course i'm we're all deeply
grateful for these american sponsors but
when you're four years old you don't
understand that so what i remembered was
just the feeling of abandonment
of being taken away he was reunited with
his parents after a few months
and later relocated to san jose where
they opened a vietnamese grocery store
it sounds like the american dream but it
came at a cost
the painful contradiction is to express
their love
they work like crazy which means they
have no time to spend with their
children
and so the there's this huge emotional
distance that grows
nguyen retreated into books creating
worlds on the page
and winning his first literary prize in
elementary school
but he didn't tell his parents they
didn't have the time to take me to the
library to get my prize
you didn't tell your parents that you'd
won the macarthur fellowship or even the
pulitzer prize
on social media i might say i want this
and this but i don't go home and tell
that to my parents because why
i don't expect my parents to read my
books they already gave up enough for me
i don't need them to give up time to
read my books
he credits his parents for his work
ethic and his persistence
he was discouraged from studying
vietnamese american literature in
college
and his first novel was initially
rejected by 13
publishers i think i was lucky in a way
that i was not successful as a writer
early
because i think if i had somehow won the
pulitzer 25 or 30
i might have been really messed up but i
actually
suffered as a writer for like more than
20 years nuend says despite his success
he's still fighting the same battles
pushing the country to reckon with
representation and collective memory
where are we now in terms of
you see us as a country and what are
your hopes for america
when i look at american history i think
that we always make two steps forward
and one
step back you know something like a 1900
percent increase in new york city
in anti-asian violence during the
pandemic for example but this stuff was
happening a century ago
i'm in los angeles 1871 17 chinese men
and boys were lynched
in downtown los angeles so my feeling
about the country
is as always suspended perpetually on
the possibility of hope and taking many
steps forward
and then being pulled back the new
yorker is calling you
the conscious of american literature
does that even seem real
no no no no no it doesn't it doesn't
seem real i just think that
i'm fulfilling the duty that anybody
owes to this country
the real impetus for me to do all these
things is not to hear myself talk
the real impetus for me to do these
things is to try to change the
circumstances
so that there will be more people with
the opportunity
to speak we don't just need one person
to speak we need
a lot of people to speak that's one of
those pieces you go wow i remember the
first piece we did with
him yeah so i could just listen to him i
mean i think we could all learn a lot
listening to what he has
it's so important to hear this
perspective i've started reading his new
book the community it is
really powerful i hope his parents were
watching they found out he won the
pulitzer prize yeah
as a macarthur and he was such a cute
little boy too i love the little boy
pictures and then you see him as an
adult very smart very
interesting great piece by james